men Papa were not afraid the music video
shows gambas on beach filled with people
dancing the mood relaxed and a feat and
yet only one month ago this part was the
scene of a deadly terror attack the
country's most successful rappers came
together for the music project an unpaid
and spontaneous reaction to the tragic
events in March and in the meantime the
song's title has become an anti-terror
slogan in Ivory Coast you for good with
artistic it's now time for us artists to
rise up against terrorism here in Ivory
Coast in Africa and around the world we
can't allow jihadist to force their
worldview upon us because God created us
with the intention that we should live
but although the music video focuses on
the beauty of combi song the popular
holiday destination has become a ghost
town since the attacks waiter Aruna
ouattara was preparing the hotel's
Sunday buffet when al-qaeda terrorists
attacked the beach although he was able
to hide just in time he witnessed the
shooting of two guests
he was also there when the music video
was made in front of the hotel for him
the songs message is exactly what is
needed to fight terrorism Nicola popper
of course it would be a lie to say that
I don't feel scared at all but all the
police who now guard the hotel give us
courage we just have to keep working if
we're afraid then we certainly can't
expect the guests to return back the
alien robot if Orion security forces had
feared attacks for some time only a few
months prior to the events on canvas on
beach terrorists attacked similar
targets in the neighboring countries of
Mali and Burkina Faso alka days envious
of the kind of attention Isis is getting
but I kata is a little bit more
ideological in focus and that is why you
see their consistency in attacking the
same types of targets hotels foreigners
mixed in of course with locals but Isis
is a little bit more indiscriminate
despite everything Aruna what are our
refuses to give up hope and he tells us
things are already looking up the first
table reservations have already been
made for the coming week the Ivorians
message for the jihadists is clear we
are not afraid of you they are very
aware that it probably won't be the last
terrorist attack in western Africa but
they just want to go back to their usual
everyday lives as soon as possible